there there is this point in the book
when um Elon sues the government or sues
NASA over awarding contracts uh in an
incentives plus structure uh which is
hey blocked Martin or Boeing uh take on
this project and then you can add 20% as
a profit margin regardless of whether it
is successful or not and then Elon
actually Sues and says hey that's not
the way you can award contracts which
anyone advising him would say that's
insane to sue the US government uh and
somehow he wins and then when the
contracts are then dealt out based upon
who can perform a task they end up or uh
SpaceX ends up getting the contracts and
then leap frogging uh the other players
um that there's a a consistent theme
about Elon kind of flouting rules
breaking rules pushing the the
boundaries in some ways that again
people would find totally inadvisable
in a lot of context um but that
particular uh incentive switch ends up
being literally the key to spacex's
success but then the key to America's
success in getting astronauts back into
orbit you know 50 years ago we sent
people to the moon and then we gave up
we didn't go back 12 or so years ago we
grounded the space shuttle and since
then haven't been able to get astronauts
from the US to the space station uh and
what you put your finger on once again
you put your finger on some other
interviewers have not yet talked about
which is it seems minor but it's huge
which is not only has he built rockets
that can send mass and astronauts into
orbit and can land and be reused which
no country or company has done have
reusable Rockets but he moved us from
Cost Plus Contracting which you
described which is take all the time you
want and whatever costs you will give
you that plus a profit this is why
Boeing became flabby this is why NASA
was not able to get astronauts into
orbit and he said no give me a mission
tell me a fixed price and then in the
book you see him walking through the
assembly line day after day saying how
do we make this vow a little bit less
expensive or this part of the nose cone
a little bit lighter and he ends up
being able to accomplish the missions at
onet the cost of a Boeing or locked and
Boeing and musk and Boeing had both
gotten after this contracts to get
astronauts to the space station around
the same time musk has had like 33
missions now sending things into orbit
and multiple missions to the space
station Boeing and NASA have yet to be
able to do a successful test flight that
gets astronauts up so moving us into the
era of fixed fee for service rather than
Cost Plus Contracting it sounds like
something only a geek like me and you
could appreciate but it's part of the
big deal oh yeah I mean I I I understood
the that if you change the incentives
you actually have a real chance um and
there are unfortunately a lot of other
areas in American life where I think the
incentives um are are messed up I'm
going to randomly share a story because
Richard Branson makes a camp
um in your book I was with Richard last
year and he talked about his Maiden
flight into space uh and he talked about
how the rocket doesn't have a bathroom
um so he wore a diaper uh on the maiden
flight um but he didn't want wearing the
diaper on the first trip to be his only
time using the diaper so he put the
diaper on the day
before then just tried it out to see if
it worked um so he he was sharing the
kind of uh detail about you know some of
the less glamorous elements um of uh
space travel there's this tension
between the public sector and
billionaires now uh in American Life uh
you used to be the head of Time Magazine
by the way I had a friend who worked for
you during that time and and people
thought very well of you now time is
owned by uh Mark benof who I believe is
a billionaire billionaires own a lot of
the major media companies elon's
obviously a billionaire
um and it it seems like there are these
gaps in what the public sector can and
can't do and so people are turning to
billionaires but then they hate turning
to billionaires because there's a real
problem with the this notion that you
need a billion dollars to get anything
done in in American Life uh I I feel
like this is one of the things that your
book touches on in various ways is that
there's something garish obviously about
uh commercial space travel being a
billionaire uh sandbox um but then if we
waited for the public sector to do it we
might be waiting forever well let's uh
make clear that even though Elon Musk
went and was with Branson when Branson
took his flight musk is not doing his
Rockets as a billionaire boy toy he's
not flying up in the Rockets himself
he's the only person who can get our us
intelligence satellites into the high
Earth orbit the only person who's been
able to uh you know send up almost 5,000
satellites to recreate the internet in
outer space and if you look this year
alone I think he will launch maybe 1,600
tons of payload and satellites into
orbit that's more than every other
country meaning China Russia the United
States and every other company combined
not only that it's four times as much as
every other company and Country combined
so it's not just a Billionaire's Boy Toy
here he's actually Transforming Our
ability uh to get into
space hey YouTube glad you're enjoying
the podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank
you